hello hello hello hello hello and
welcome to the Simpson left Co podcast
welcome welcome how are you Sims II I'm
doing well how are you left Co E oh I'm
so good oh you're wearing maroon today
shocker I love the color oh we know you
do you can't wear it because if you
blush you'd look like a human tonight I
wouldn't wear it I mean you're just
you're Johnny cool pants man I don't do
that stuff Johnny cool pants we have an
awesome show we are gonna be having
Martellus Bennett joining us a little
bit later we're finally gonna get to
Sims as linebackers we're gonna dig into
the out of left go field hat for a
number of topics because I know that you
guys like it and I'm back on Pepe Silvia
whoa
last time I did Pepe Silvia I predicted
the Eagles would win the Super Bowl
and it happens and Gostkowski missed
those kicks well I've got another one
and you gotta stay tuned because I'm in
the basement and I got a whole box of
Pepe with your name on what the hell is
Pepe Silvia it's from the show it's
always sunny in philadelphia right and
there was a sketch that I'm mentioning
right here we're seeing the show I've
heard of it okay I'm not wasting my time
you know that we're nominated for a
Webby I mean I saw the email yeah so
Sims and Lefko we are nominated for a
webby we are currently in second place
behind Bill Simmons for best sports
podcast I think it is we're gonna lose
no no screw that I need you guys go
online go register for the web's I'm
gonna put it I'm gonna pin it for a
tweet help us out if we can upset bins
Bill Simmons
well then I'll feel like Ben Simmons but
we can upset Bill Simmons I'm gonna make
sure that Simms does something really
embarrassing to reward you guys for
voting so that's good it's at the cost
of Simms support us with the webbie's
the amount of people that took my side
in bear vs. lion we talked about it at
dinner
shocking yes I've read some of them to
you yes are you coming anymore team bear
you still team lion I mean I guess I
have to go look at some of these archaic
videos which I don't even want to watch
really watch it we talked about that
dinner but yeah I guess I'm definitely
on the fence a little bit more than I
was you come a little bit to the Bears
think so certainly Harry can
well you know what I said we know what I
think started to get me I think this is
where it got me like alright let's go
back to the San Antonio LeBron James
conversation oh what a horrible athlete
I mean he's cramping up he's not in good
shape
no the freakiest athletes cramp up
that's what happened to LeBron James and
I think the one guy that made the point
about the know muscle endurance for the
Lions get tired from that abhi issue yes
because they're all muscle there's no
fat on them and that's where I think I
was like you're right so he'd have to
kill that bear within the first three
minutes that happened that's probably
not happening right right
it finally happened I finally got you
yeah I guess I've watched the videos
first I got to see the video evidence to
make sure all right that's got it I want
to say farewell I think it's very sad
that Titan strength and conditioning
coach my man Watterson retires after 32
so we just talked about same week that
we talked about him ah you know what he
actually would be a fun guest we're
gonna have him on we really show you
need to have him off because he probably
has 9 million stories yes he's one of my
favorite coaches that was ever around
but he sounds like a loony but no he's a
loony bit and I think this is what I
envisioned happening ok it's the new a
New England staff down there right John
Robinson for Abel's there yes and he was
like you want me here at what time how
long do I gotta stay here I haven't done
it like this I'm retiring see a [ __ ]
later well there's a quote this quote
was as I was preparing for another off
season to begin it became clear to me
that it was time for me to step down and
retire water since Thursday he got the
schedule continued with this man when I
heard a former player share the story of
me doing naked headstand push-ups on a
Webby Award nominated podcast the first
part of that was actually true yeah and
it kind of sounds like for Abel was in
he's like 4 a.m. workouts and
Waterston's like and I've been in the
game three days how do I organize this I
don't know I'm just getting out of this
one yeah that's what I would imagine
happen you know I got a little
experience with that when I was with the
Denver Broncos and Josh McDaniels came
over to take over the reins of the
organization and of course he did things
New England way and knowing little ways
can be brutal it's tough there's no
doubt about it especially on the
training staff and the people better
you know the actual and you know the
workout guys what the hell am I trying
to work out coach workout trainers -
yeah so both of them I mean New England
this is what they will do you in Denver
or one New England like when you're hurt
they basically make rehab so miserable
that you go hmm I can limp out there
today and make it happen because they
just don't want you to be here at 4:00
in the morning get your rehab done
before we start meetings and this sucks
for the players but also the trainer has
to be that's where I was going exactly
right so they're like some of the
old-school trainers that the Broncos I
think they were like in total culture
shock the first year because they were
of course working more hours than they
ever had previously number of Patriots
stories we're gonna get to it a little
bit but this is the time of the year
where every year people forget and me
and Sims get frustrated by a lot when it
comes to the NFL but one thing that
always gets me going is when people
forget that we just talked about
something this time last year and we got
to go through all this crap again and
the big theme of this week is showing up
remember last year
Fletcher Cox didn't come to a voluntary
camp and it was like oh no he doesn't
care how is this gonna set back the
defense oh man one of his best seasons
of his career right and they win the
Super Bowl and he is a huge reason why
but today Kaleo mad didn't show I don't
know if you'll be able to get out of a
three-point stands and come off the edge
with their screwed line season over a
turd you're done but we just dealt with
this last year
Khalil backs not gonna sit in the
meeting and listen to Gruden today it's
over it's [ __ ] over I mean I know now
that drives me crazy the Khalil Mack one
though trust me it's a little different
cuz Gruden's invite get that well I mean
it is not no sure with Anza yeah but
I've put Gruden's different than
position right Gruden would be like him
you know like he's gonna take it to that
next letter you also would be like I
mean he'll I mean if I was built like
Khalil Mack - I wouldn't come here
either I just show up and be like hey
[ __ ] you all play you think so I mean
nothing Gruden's getting a little at
like bent out of shape about it I'm Cleo
Mac as you know we've met him before
I would think he is contact the team to
go I'm not gonna be here for the first
few days whatever it may be they're not
worried
as a coil Mac and the Ziggy ounces of
the world and whatever who right they're
professional he's already in shape he
hasn't gotten out of anything it's
possible for Khalil Mac right I mean
he's like a chisel piece of iron yeah
but yeah even the Ronde book Ronde
Barber the Derrick Brooks of the teams I
mean they weren't always there day one
they've earned the stripes to miss a day
or two or just show up when they're
ready to go yeah it's funny one of my
follow-up questions with Sims could you
please imitate Gruden learning that Mack
didn't show up and you did it without me
even asking
I just be walking around doing curls it
was my shirt off the amount of think
pieces that are gonna come out about is
cool Mac really a leader for not coming
in during a transition don't you need
your leaders to be there we just
experienced all this now the flip side
is O'Dell right O'Dell showed up
professional Dave is so happy jiggle the
camera Gabe give jiggle it for us what's
interesting though about the Odell is
one he's still doing the left go
marketing plan he is every Wednesday
night we publish a podcast and Odell
publishes a video of him working out
right but then I hear that the beginning
of the workouts is strength and
conditioning and physical rehabilitation
yeah we talked about this last year
right he's gonna get better workouts not
at the training facility probably I mean
he's working out ready to go no matter
what this was a visual like VR thing
right its Palmer said all the right
stuff he's been great during this entire
thing yeah well because I'm sure he's
like are you [ __ ] kidding me we're
gonna trade him away when I get here to
become the head coach I mean I've been
salivating over coaching this guy yeah
and we're gonna get rid of him so this
is the other angle you have to think up
to the workouts you're right I mean he
probably probably would get more benefit
doing his own but regardless he gets to
be there gets to meet some of these
coaches people that he hasn't met right
and the other thing too is he does I
mean I think Odell wants to play for the
Giants and be here in New York City and
it's a new offense a new system so
that's the first thing that you'll learn
today too is he's gonna start to learn
the language of some of the base plays
to get that you know in his brain a
little bit so those are the power
that doesn't happen until Phase two I
just I looked it up the first two weeks
of nine weeks phase one and adjusting in
rehab so there's no phase two is when
you can start talking about concepts and
all that stuff so there's no going in
meeting rooms is that what they're
saying I mean I can't I don't really
think that happens today there was a
Giants fan the office and he came out to
me he goes you know Odell came today and
I'm sure that now Mara is a little bit
more comfortable giving him a copy
showed up one time that Dan out now 100
million there's 100 million our guy Kyle
Brant
over a good morning football I love Kyle
yeah I really do I just thought he had a
really bad take that I saw on the
internet today if I saw Kyle Bryant I
would do do things I'd go one here some
tequila
let's get sloshed and great job
supporting the Eagles during the
Superbowl run but he said today he said
Odell just show up and be the best
employee possible it will end the way it
does in the corporate world with money
that's we keep saying Jarvis Landry
showed up and he got traded to Cleveland
yeah Odell showed up last year and got
nothing and almost lost his knee in the
preseason game and then got hurt that
that holes show up and get yeah Emily
disagree Landry showed everybody he was
the perfect soldier last year and got
nothing done right I mean they franchise
tag them but it wasn't for his benefit
they held him hostage because they just
didn't want to let him walk out the door
for free you're right now the stories of
that it's very highly unlikely that
Odell gets traded yeah of course
you think so well I mean I don't think
it's like highly highly unlikely I still
think there's a chance I don't think
this story dies out to me until a week
after the draft that's when I go OK and
I go finally okay teams got their roster
they're ready the end of the story Odell
is gonna be on the Giants because up to
the draft certainly we know this could
still happen after the draft there might
be teams that wanted a receiver and
needed a difference-maker didn't get
what they want and they might go
okay let's reevaluate this whole
situation but at the end of the day
again I just think it's a really risky
thing for the Giants to do PR wise and
on the field wise Eli Manning is not the
same guy without Odell Beckham jr. it's
14 touchdowns and 14 interceptions
without Odell with Odell at 66 touchdown
twenty nine interceptions so it's a much
better style play plus you're gonna
worry about the backlash like we talked
about right he goes he goes to some
other team
yeah and tears it up and we're all gonna
every New Yorker Gabe over here is gonna
you know cry a river for Daisy word he
was here five days a week he says so I
mean it's risky and again can we just
say it one more time I mean the [ __ ]
guy all he's done I mean okay he got
into a fight with Josh Norman on the
field that's probably the worst thing
he's done right and from everything I've
heard this is the worst thing when he
Dovid josh trice head that was the worst
and if you've talked to anybody in the
NFL the one thing I constantly hear is
there was homeless homophobic slurs the
whole game towards you know there's a
bunch of issues there so okay there's
that okay the day trip to Miami on the
day off I know it's not the greatest
look but I mean come on this as bad as I
can Tonio Brown throwing the huge Gator
a jug all over the sidelines in
Baltimore or doing Facebook live after a
PI off game no it's not but for some
reason you know ones like this
charismatic nice guy and I want to be
like they're the same person basically
but I don't get it welcomes you gave
your take yes and now I'd like to give
mine I know you're going not only do I
think so I want you to just let me do
this let it breathe right not only do I
think Odell should be traded I know
where he needs to go I know this very
well
the 49ers need to trade for Odell
Beckham jr. because they are the 1981
49ers and they can relaunch that
dominant dynasty of the 80s and it
starts and ends with Odell but I'd like
to start off first with the coaches this
is possible Bill Walsh
bill Walsh's first college coaching job
Sims was a low-level assistant coach for
a public university in California his
first NFL job wouldn't you know was with
their Raiders in Walsh's turnaround
season with the Niners he started his
backup quarterback for the first time in
December Montana
led them to a comeback win in that game
and they finished the season six and 10
right current head coach
to the 49ers Kyle Shanahan his first
colleague trap his first college
coaching job was a low-level assistant
coach for a public university in
California that's when he you see he
thought he was Tyler Durden from
five-course right there his first job
was with the current coach of the
Raiders and in Shanahan's first
turnaround season he started his backup
quarterback for the first time in
December Jimmy G led them to a comeback
win and they finished the season six and
ten let's talk about those quarterbacks
shall we Joe Montana was born to an
Italian family in the Midwest
surprisingly he didn't play quarterback
for his high school team until his
junior year at six-foot-two he was
drafted by a legendary coach named Bill
after the first round man he's drafted
in the third round yes yeah Dan Phil
Simms should have been there Jimmy
Garoppolo was born to an Italian family
in the Midwest surprisingly he didn't
play quarterback for his high school
team until his junior year at
six-foot-two he was drafted by a
legendary coach named Bill after the
first round but now to the goat and the
missing piece the new goat Jerry Rice
was a three-sport star in the south
dominating in football basketball and
track who then attended college in his
home state
he was the third receiver taken in his
draft yet he went on to win NFC
Offensive Rookie of the Year Odell
Beckham jr. was a three-sport star in
the south dominating in football
basketball and track who then attended
college in his home state he was wooden
chin no the third receiver taken in his
draft yet he went on to win the NFL
Offensive Rookie of the Year and I know
it seems crazy but there's more the 1981
49ers team went on to rumble to a 13 and
3 record and win the Super Bowl in the
Pontiac Silverdome it was the first
Super Bowl held in that stadium that
shared a name with a car company and was
unique because its roof had technology
that was nowhere else in the NFL granted
it was
Rufe that had plenty of issues early on
well the Super Bowl this season Sims
it's in Atlanta right
it's mercedes-benz Stadium it's gonna be
the first car held in a stadium that
shares a name with a car company do they
having roof problems too well I'll tell
you what they have technology in their
roof that is not seen anywhere else in
NFL but they've already had some
technological issues early on if the
49ers trade for Odell Beckham jr. they
will launch the new dynasty of Niners
football they will become the 81 San
Francisco 49ers John Lynch make the call
let's go get it done
I mean come on I mean come on it's right
Pepe Silvia is real I don't know of
anybody all like listening to us anymore
though we'll be so hardcore 49ers fans
on this pie I didn't care everybody
liked what I can't listen to the [ __ ] I
just I I want them to get Odell so bad
right because like I'm seeing stories
about Eli Manning being okay that Odell
wasn't at his camp and all that stuff
and I'm I wanted to be like that's like
the guy who knows retiring soon be like
hey man come on like let's all let's all
get together it's just I don't think the
Giants had the juice do you still think
they can make the run well I know III
think the Giants can make the run I'm
not gonna sit here and say they're gonna
make the run cuz the quarterback I mean
that's that's not gonna be the reason no
they're gonna have to do it with good
well-rounded football good quarterback
play defensive play a little bit like we
saw two years ago when they you know
beat Dallas two out of the three times
you know two out of the Dallas's three
losses whatever it may be
yeah you know listen I think he's gonna
be a really a whole lot better in this
offense compared to what he was in no
matter what we're gonna see one
schirmer's gonna use him to the best of
his ability right to every comment that
Shermer has made has been very decisive
and it's been I won him I need him and
it's you they needed a strong like voice
to come in that isn't gonna do the
back-and-forth nonsense they they
IIIi can't remember if we talked about
this last week but they gotta be careful
with the way they treat him right here
they have to you know further all those
out there that think oh the Giants have
all this of all the leverage cuz he's
under contract they really don't hear
the situation they don't I mean he's the
best player in their team was wrong yeah
I agree
I mean don't show up that's the only
power that NFL players it's okay if he
shows up for this but maybe OTAs maybe
training camp he doesn't show up
whatever it may be he's putting his best
foot forward and trying to be that type
of guy that's okay even if he gets
injured out there and this type of
workout at least it's in their facility
and they got to pay him yeah
so I look at that but what was my point
Hermer yeah no but oh they just got to
be careful they need to kind of kiss his
butt you know when when when the rest of
the 31 teams realized that Odell doesn't
like the Giants anymore and he doesn't
want to be there that's really gonna
lower the trade value cuz everyone's
gonna go well why would right that's
what happens right for you guys well why
would it why would I give you two first
rounders he's not even gonna play this
year I'll just wait til he's a free
agent next year whatever it may be
yeah so they got to be careful with how
they treat him here over the next few
weeks because he could act like mr.
[Laughter]
let's get to some other topics because
O'Dell honestly I could talk to you
about Odell for years yes so reach your
hand in there I need a computer charger
let's see what topic comes up next and
anybody go into my Woody's my room but
these are so small I can't even get to
look at them
alright what's our first topic pack of
Patriots pack of Patriots wouldn't you
know I don't even know what you're
talking about yeah there's three
Patriots stories that we need to get to
today okay you pick out the first one
here key and the first Patriots story
that Sims pulls is the hoodie chastised
Gronk what was that chastised chastise
hashed I'm sorry kind of chastity belt
on them so apparently this came sex this
came out with one of the Boston
reporters right at one point early last
season the hoodie chastised crunk in
unit that means berated yelled at
diny and in front of the players he just
did to me by explaining that [ __ ]
word new do me do you know that you know
others begin be fine I didn't say any of
that or use that voice apparently in
front of the players he berated Gronk
for being a TB 12 client so that was a
story that came out today yeah I'm
curious on a few things one like we
always hear about him berating Brady and
we celebrate Brady for being able to
take it yeah do you think Gronk would
have been able to take that in front of
the team does he did he do that to Gronk
when you were there - yeah I can't
remember a specific time when he'll do
it to anybody it doesn't really matter
who you are there's just there's no
boundary there at all like zero boundary
now this is interesting too because you
know like I saw the headline of the
story and I read just a little boredom
underneath it I didn't know all the
detail that was the old the detail yeah
I mean of course that like Bill doesn't
like that okay that bill was yeah we
know that though but but I also go why
does Bill really care about a guy that's
like the best in shape guy on your
football team because I think that he
was picking the guy to get the message
across about T beat well right and start
messing with it don't do it anymore I
can't do it to Gronk right and not like
the newest linebacker that just picked
it up - he was like I need to pick
someone that can do it right well I
think that would probably be his method
behind that yes is to be that guy or
whatever else yeah he's not happy that
his teammates losing control he wants to
know what his guys are going work out
wise yes you know but by no stretch of
the imagination is this the first time
that happens in the NFL I mean every
team I was on I mean I mean there was
always a handful of guys in the locker
room where we got done with practice and
meetings on the afternoon and I'd go
where are you going there going I'm
gonna go work out with my trainer oh and
I mean even during the season so that
goes on and yes teams don't like it and
usually it's kind of kept private
yes but of course he knows everything
here is leaking all this stuff in New
England right I really don't know
there's a lot of leaks going there is a
lot of stuff coming out well they have a
lot new people in positions that if
because a lot of people have left over
the last is true so the people that were
there they could search that you're not
very heard the John Robbins
and all those guys right or the John
rabe you know all the guys that were
there that have left they've heard the
stories from the people that are there
right they don't care interesting right
all right let's go to another Packer
Patriots new coach Bret Bielema yes what
Bret Bielema is acting as a consultant
and scout for the Patriots even going as
far as wearing Patriots gear at some pro
days okay it was mentioned of course
that the Patriots have had some success
drafting former players of BLM including
James White Detrick wise Trey flowers
from Wisconsin and Arkansas Bielema Greg
Schiano
yeah Belichick finds the guys that he
respects and kind of brings them in
right but what are some other coaches
and programs that Belichick really
admires that you've noticed well I mean
of course Urban Meyer Urban Meyer I mean
there was always the mr. Y Hernandez was
there that's why Brandon Spikes were
there those type of players because I
think he knew when I draft an Urban
Meyer type player it's a lot like Nick
Saban it's no-nonsense they're used to
physical practices they're used to being
yelled out by their coaches when they
mess up yeah so that would be one right
off the bat that I know that that bill
has great respect for yeah you said she
a no you know Bielema it's interesting
because I don't know Brett Bielema he
seems like a true football guy I
wouldn't exactly think that their Styles
meshed together right but I think that
probably their overall philosophy of
football is a little bit similar where
Bielema is a like you said Wisconsin
Arkansas big people probably has a
little I for that position in that
Heartland that's what Bill liked about
it you almost put a lot of offensive
line Kennedy yeah yes thanks dude but I
just found it interesting that they kind
of scooped up this coach that was let go
but this is what he's immediately in the
Scout this is why Bill's amazing cuz
Bill is the smartest guy in the NFL and
then also goes I have more to learn
where the rest of the football is just
like play I learned we have our skies
were in that 1988 I'm good I don't need
to learn any more Bill Walsh taught me
everything and here's like Bill
Belichick he's changed his motto ten
different times style of play we're
gonna throw the ball where a run team oh
I want tight ends you know I need the
Jamie Colin type linebackers I mean he's
always willing to evolve and he's always
willing to get better ideas whether it's
hiring Rob Ryan on the staff I mean he's
he's not he wants to hear and learn
football and more idea that has to be
the most exciting and complementary
thing to be told as a coach that Bella
checks like I need to learn from you
yeah well he's just gonna take it from
anybody like the year I've told you with
Chip Kelly being there Chip Kelly was at
a football he was at our practices like
three or four times and I kept going
what is Bill getting out of Chip Kelly
and then all of a sudden we started
getting ready for training camp and I
was like ah I got it I've we got all
these coded word plays to go faster the
line of scrimmage that's what he's been
talking about Chip Kelly well how do you
organize this so closely one aspect
taking one and he's letting chip hang
around he's gonna let chip steal what he
wants and he's gonna get knowledge that
way but yes and in that year when I was
working for the New England Patriots as
the self-proclaimed pitch boy we broke
the record for most plays in a year by
any NFL team and probably and I had a
broken ship all those meetings with chip
because he figured out how chip did it
chip taught him
yeah and he continued to grow off of
this amazing it is it's funny because
the last one in this one with the
Patriots was joint practices which we
always talk about with Belichick were
they doing against this year well no the
story came out that Matt Patricia
wants to do joint practices he's open up
for business okay and I only put this in
here for one reason right to remind the
rest of the NFL that if you're an actual
contender this year do not do a joint
practice with the Patriots right Jaguars
Eagles Steelers Chargers any team that
has a chance to make a run this year do
not do a joint practice because bill is
getting more out of it than you are
but I think that team should do joint
practice yeah thank you for that's where
you should say can you put but not with
Bill no don't do anything with Bill just
like we we finally you know we talked
about it of course leading up to the AFC
Championship Diana Rossini right let's
give her some credit cuz she said the
one thing the Patriots said they looked
at the most during the preparation for
that game yes was the joint practices
I will say though that when I hear like
Mariota or deshaun Watson talking about
what it was like to see Brady work
during those days that's why Detroit
wants to do it yes cuz they want to go
they were they want to probably own New
England cuz he wants to go listen this
is what New England's done this is where
I came from see how good they are see
what they do
yes buy into what I think it's good to
do early on right if you're a contender
don't whole agreed left go with you all
the way but again another example right
what Bill cutting-edge once again out
he's the starter of joint practices that
do with this often you know why he does
joined practices why because he keeps
his team fresh for one it's not through
like the stale doldrum days of you know
training camp or you practice against
the same guy you look across and
Gronkowski goes damn that's Trey flowers
I've seen them for 35 days in a row now
yeah this is getting boring yeah so you
keep them fresh mentally and you keep
them fresh physically and I know people
are gonna go what do you mean it's a
scrimmage practice no because there's no
Scout team
that's where people lose out on this you
get quality reps you don't take some of
the quantity [ __ ] reps that come
about during training camp so now your
defense they don't have to do scout team
for the offense they can just wait oh
we're practicing as Jacksonville defense
we'll go out when Jacksonville's offense
goes out and it's a real rep instead of
like reading a card and going well we
want you to do this and you have not
really do it at 100% so against genius
yes don't do it with your colleges right
all right reach back in there new topic
I'm going to see LeBron James tonight do
you know that I do know that I'm excited
jealous so I didn't bring it up good I'm
wearing my element LeBron shoes
Oh big offseason
okay so uh-oh big offseason is not the
same thing as whoa big offseason
oh whoa big offseason is whoa this guy
is doing some work though Oh big
offseason is you did something wrong in
the offseason and right now it's Thomas
Davis Thomas Davis Sam Thomas offended
four games he came out did a very
tearful apology he talked about
accidentally taking an estrogen blocker
yes yes you're right that's what it was
you are the most anti cheating person
I've ever met mine
yeah what is your sentiments towards
Thomas Davis gosh I mean I haven't
Antonio Gates I know and I know both of
these guys and I just like Hall of Fame
caliber all right and I would never
envision them cheating and I mean
there's it's a lifelong of good deeds
and doing things the right way but yes
does it make me wonder yes this is why
this is the number one thing I want done
I want the NFL to start when it comes to
peds I want to know what they tested
positive for if you're gonna do it you
need to be embarrassed you're gonna
scare people away from it once they
can't use the oh I bought something over
G&C or oh I took adderall to concentrate
typical thing that here that Thomas
Davis said and what a lot of people said
is I should have been more aware of what
I was putting my body no I'm taking this
for years and apparently I got a false
flag for an estrogen blocker is what he
said I know you know and Thomas Davis is
one of those guys former Man of the Year
comes my spleen yeah I mean that's but
no you know you said it though I hate
cheaters
I hate Thomas Davis is like the pinnacle
in disguise
I know and I don't know what to think
about it because that is too I mean as
you know and as you document with me all
the time I mean I'm just so I'm just a
quarterback and I'm obsessed with what I
eat and you know I put it I know
everything I put in my body and I just
have a hard time believing some of these
guys are oh I made this a mistake I've
been watching everything I have eaten so
you're not believe in Thai I don't know
what to believe anymore tell me the
truth I'm skeptical of everybody I
really am like what do you think the end
look realistically see I get in this
argument a lot with my friends later so
let's have this conversation like what
how much do you think of the NFL is
taking performance and sting drugs I am
always in the more than I I know but
people all my friends and and even my
dad and other people I respect they
think I'm low like I always say it's
like five to ten people five handful of
guys in every team I'm gonna say five to
six guys in every we're talking like HGH
we're yeah whatever it is to make you
perform better and I just get the
pushback below in the league think
there's more oh they go like it's 50/50
that's what that's the talk all the time
right they think and they think I'm
being naive and I
you know I have a like I've always told
you I just been around too many freak
athletes where all I've seen them do is
you know eat McDonald's smoke weed drink
liquor and have chocolate shakes and
they get faster and stronger and we can
get back into the parent issue or
whatever and you're saying it's more
like natural like they're just gifted
athletes you're saying that they not
need performance I don't think it's
right it's the guys look and I think
it's the Johnny under overachievers in
the world that didn't make it in the NFL
who they'd like to believe that I didn't
take it they are that's why they're
there I'll also say this though I am
saying that I am going to believe Thomas
Davis yeah just because I don't I think
he's had a track record in which he
deserves three credit to be believed
right but I'm gonna say that it's the
guys like the gates and the Thomas
Davis's who are at the end of their
career I know that may be the question
may be needed there but that's unfair of
me to put on them I know I'm gonna
believe Thomas Davis yeah I am right but
I agree with you it's time we just start
saying when it's for right what they
needs to cuz if it's from robitussin it
happened by accident or if it was like a
cough syrup or whatever then like they
should put that out and kind of
exonerate them too I just don't think
that NFL wants to look bad at going look
it came from something dumb but we still
have to penalize because it was a went
off I don't care I mean you know okay so
smoking it out of the bong is dumb but
they had no problems suspending you for
that so yeah again it's cheating and a
lot of the times it's illegal in our
country it's like it's more than that
and it's about setting example for young
kids it's about safety for yourself the
cheater because maybe you the cheater
you're supposed to be two hundred and
forty pounds but now you've racked up
and injected steroids and you're 255 and
all sudden your ACL tears out of
no-contact injury why maybe because
you're bigger and stronger than you
shouldn't be and then it's not fair to
me who's Johnny natural guy over here I
just been eating Oreos my whole life and
also oh I get to get blindsided by the
guy who's 20 pounds stronger and like
1/10 faster because he cheated and I ate
Oreos
you know that's [ __ ] up I have an
issue with that yeah and I have an issue
with it all together like I'm gonna
throw another guy under the bus in this
conversation not to like totally kill
the guy but there's Trent Murphy
Washington Redskins last year right PD
test well who cares three years 22
million dollar contract with the bill
oh that scared him off the peds hole
[ __ ] he'll never do them again you mean
you got 22 million dollars for cheatin I
mean that's that's the problem it's a
problem all over sports right now right
Melky Cabrera suspended 50 games in
baseball comes back 15 million a year
doesn't even so what's these of them
what do you say to the people that I
hear on talk radio all the time that go
I say let them all do steroids know them
all it's good for us yeah that's just
like that's just the newest dumb thing
I've ever heard like it's so ridiculous
oh yeah now they want them to act crazy
five minutes ago they want them to be
normal now they wanted to be crazy and
kill each other it's cheating it's
illegal in our country a lot of these
substances they're illegal okay and we
don't even know the long-term effects of
them so none of that's stupid I mean
yeah you know we just don't know I mean
it till somebody you know all of a
sudden like wakes up one morning as I'm
like man I got three nuts I'm in trouble
I'm just gonna fall yeah right yeah all
right yeah I know I know you're a non
cheater that's why I do that one big
thank you yeah it got it off my chest to
feel better all right next one okay why
are we still doing this I asked myself
this every day when we started this show
no this isn't there for this Wisconsin
cornerback Nick Nelson tore his meniscus
in a private NFL team work out and see
state defensive end Kentavious Street
tore his ACL at a private workout with
the Giants last year Sydney Jones busted
his Achilles in a private workout these
guys get nothing they are gonna follow
the draft they're gonna go lower than
they should all for a private workout
which you have the game film
you have the combine yet these guys are
going there with no insurance and doing
these private workouts and that's two
guys this year the contain be a street
kid the defenseman you liked a lot yeah
I mean he's gonna be like a mid-round
type of pick that's now a probably gonna
be a late round no doubt about it and
probably won't be able to play it all
next year so that you're right I mean
again it's your careers off to a why
star still doing this it's a great
question left go it really is if I was
an agent if I would let my guy go to
play no I know it's uh I guess you'd
have to be a little bit like dependent
on the guy right but you're right I mean
some of the top
guys I'd be like don't even mess with it
who cares or you got that or the teams
have to start doing something they have
to start putting themselves at risk okay
we get to work you out if you hurt your
knee and tear your meniscus we have to
pay you a million dollars yeah this has
to be something like that's your percent
right I mean you're you're screwing them
out of a million dollar so you have to
pay them up because I'm sure the team
each team gets 30 right 30 private
workout they're just trying to crank
them out you're right there look at him
stuff but yeah there needs to be some
loss for the team because this is a kid
that everyone believes that these kids
are paid in in education well guess what
now they have nothing yeah they're
sitting there rehabbing with no income
coming right like to me I just I saw
these stories like why are we still
doing yeah you're right good that's a
it's a good job by you you're right it's
it's uh again where the players podcast
we care about what we do it's just I
feel like there's only one person
getting screwed it's the players and
then just one left
Oh Oh super-sized left go sprinkle
super-sized sprinkle alive super-sized
sprinkles we were we were talking about
offensive minds at dinner the other
night and I began to realize that three
of the best young offensive mind
scratched that the three best young
offensive minds in the NFL share
something in common they coach Kristen's
Kyle Shanahan agreed top three by
receiver coach of the NFL yes
played wide receiver at techs oh yeah
all right Sean McVeigh right
definitely when the best offensive minds
the NFL played wide receiver at Miami of
Ohio I didn't know that one that was a
new one from Josh McDaniel right
offensive coordinator for the Patriots
played wide receiver at John Carroll man
some sorry-ass wide out wide receivers
but it just made me realize that the
three best young offensive minds in the
NFL not including like gates and stuff
but I think these three are the top
three yeah all played wide rim and then
Sean Payton but he's a head coach young
you're right you're right what could
being a wide receiver give you to be a
great offensive mind because we were
talking about this at dinner kyle is so
good at getting wide receivers open
right I feel
all three of those guys are great at
route combination right and and fine and
then also evaluating wide receiver
talent that's not super expensive right
that you could like Robert woods yeah
what an idiot apparently they were not
wrong McVeigh was able to see that you
know yeah but what do you think that
position allows them as an offensive
coordinator okay so the first thing I
would go to is they like getting that
position off right like they like they
have an invested interest in going like
I like when my receivers put up numbers
and do that like so they wanted to work
for them because they see themselves in
the similar well sure how would I want
the ball right that's how they see it
right just you know just like a
quarterback does sometimes as an
offensive game planner I think that's
for one I think too they can evaluate
the receivers and also go okay this
receiver is good at these three routes
this receiver is good at those three
routes I'm gonna always have them
running those routes to put them in
position to succeed and then also they
can think about man what are some other
ways that I would like to get open and
in bunches or whatever it may be and
what rats were my favorite routes to run
verses coverages well it's just writing
to me it's like a lot of offensive minds
our quarterbacks yeah and they think
from the quarterback position what are
the throws you want to make what are
what are the protections you want to see
what route combinations do you like but
these guys are almost doing it backwards
yeah they're going which are the routes
that get us the most open because then
that's the easiest throw for the
quarterback I think that's how they're
looking at it yeah Kyle's looking at
going how can I get these four guys in
the best position to be open right cuz
that's a lot easier than what is my
quarterback like to throw and then how
could i free up the post yeah you know
yes I just think they're reverse
engineering the offense I think you're
right I mean I never really thought of
the angle in general but I think it's
all those things combined their ability
to be creative because they want to get
receivers open their ability to evaluate
them their ability to know what routes
they used to like to run against certain
coverages I also think they also keep
going I was just also gonna say like
it's just it's a great I mean I've never
been around a receiver that doesn't love
Sean McVeigh or Kyle Shetty that's what
I'm saying I mean they love them like
they're always call that's my goal Kozma
guy yeah cotton because kids was the
same thing rapper because they get him
the ball and receivers of course it's a
smart play politically even though these
guys aren't doing it politically but
they're the biggest pains and the asses
on the football team plain and simple I
mean no we only hear about Odell Beckham
jr. and Antonio Brown is Brian but I can
promise you get dez bryant's a pain in
the ass and so is aj green and go down
the list they are that's just the way
they are and for that to always feel
like oh we're getting the ball coach is
trying to get it to us it just keeps
everything in a positive guy framework
it's just something I thought about I
think it's interested is interesting oh
speaking of interesting this next guy is
very interesting and we've been saying
for a long time that we want one of the
Bennett brothers were the players
podcast we think there will be here guys
he's gonna be coming on coming so we're
gonna go now to our awesome interview
with the main man
Martellus Bennett I'll try to get to my
mic great so I could get you you can do
whatever you want even if you want to
just pick it up you can do whatever you
do the Joe Thomas is this a podcast
it is a podcast I got my own podcast do
you it's not as big deal as this one I
don't know man I feel like you're
creating like an incubator of all yes
think about Kobe was celebrated because
when he was leaving he talked to all
these really smart people and he said I
took something and we were like genius
do the same [ __ ] yeah but he had Glen
Keane and yes and John Williams score in
his films I can you imagine what are
they big time you know Glen Keane it's
like it's like okay he's like Kobe say
Michael Jordan come here magic come on
John Williams play for you right now
John Williams on every movie fene that
you grew up loving so John Williams the
Harry Potter catch along well he did the
Imperial March according to googly
you're right Hans Zimmer I play Hans
Zimmer and he enya remember oh yes Hans
Zimmer's like as mine goes
Elfman John Williams and in both of you
intellectual [ __ ] we've already
started yes this is Martellus Bennett
for the longest time man we have we have
loved the openness in which you speak
the honesty the intelligence we build
ourselves as the players podcast because
when it comes to fighting for money we
will always take the side of the players
we were just talking about guys doing
these private workouts and getting hurt
and how is the team not on the hook for
any of that I just wanted to say I'm
excited to have you because you've been
a breath of fresh air now for like a
decade so thank you oh thank you I'm
gonna play for a decade you did music
man I mean do you know do you remember
seeing me pregame in Tampa when you were
the Dallas Cowboys I remember you
remember that yeah it was like look at
this guy coming over we talked we had a
great talk yeah and you were we were
laughing because what's his name Jason
Garrett's brother oh yeah John and he
was over here having a conversation it's
like two hours before the game and John
is behind him like watch waiting for the
conversation enemy and he's like where
your little that coming he's always I
mean I think looking back at that at
John as a coach I think he wanted the
best for me that's right right but
sometimes when you have the student you
have to teach in different ways right so
there's different ways that everybody
learn like I'm not gonna learn the same
way that Jason Witt is right right right
method that you thought was gonna work
on me may not work so as a teacher your
job is to readjust it's not the students
job to read yeah agreed right literally
talked about this last week about
teaching quarterbacks why is it always
yell at them at the board
oh it's teaching anything a teacher yeah
class teaching my daughter to do
different things like it sometimes you
have to figure out how they learn best
and your job is to get the message to
yes and that so with that in mind yeah
I've realized that I've listened to a
bunch of your interviews and I don't
want to ask questions to you I want you
to have control so that's why we're
gonna mix it up a little bit
I have topics that you get to choose
from you get to turn or choose how this
interview goes we have five categories
table Turner Sims special over/under
tale of two offenses or Martellus PR
you're screwed either way
yeah you're pretty much screwed it's got
the sim special special what do you know
are these questions
okay yeah this one's a little bit this
is I don't know what the questions gonna
be yeah so reach in there Jim special
sim ex one of his patent football
question who really impresses you right
now who did you have a hard time
battling oh so every time giving
examples this is what I do to power your
time a player comes in Sims this goes I
got Ashley this question change it up so
up yours okay all right what do you got
I'm gonna go this is the Sims special
okay you ready for this crap I got a lot
of special I want to ask you actually
but the first one I want to ask you is
New England Patriots offense versus the
Green Bay Packers offense
it was my special first so take that
damn thing away but because I am I'm
just gonna set the table like the
Packers offense I mean I've been here
four years just going it's Aaron Rodgers
it's crap they don't do anything it's
very simple you're agreeing I can
already tell and the New England
Patriots offense is like advanced
algebra compared to that so I just
wanted you to kind of wax poetically
about that I think that from for me I
don't think there's a office coordinator
that is better than Josh McCain right
right the preparation the way they calls
plays the way they put his game plans to
attack yeah defenses I've never seen
anything like in my career got you and I
played for five teams six teams and how
many different coaches yeah I've never
seen one game plan the way that he does
in the way that he puts players in
position to succeed I think as a coach
your job is to take your talent and put
them in places in position to succeed at
whatever it is that you want them
achieved right so I know that's Herto
it's hard to live up to that because
you're right he is special like that so
then just talk about what jumped out to
you about lack of Green Bay office and
think the in Green Bay I struggled like
I struggled in the office in Green Bay
right I think a lot like it's not tight
in friendly you
the Patriot office is tidy and friendly
there's a lot of scene balls there's a
lot of deep overall sight
there's a lot of movie around never
movie around like in positions that you
were being a slot like there's like the
way they use the under routes right a
lot of quick passes because I'm a guy
like the thing I loved about Joshua is
that they knew to give me the ball
early and Tom liked to give me the balls
at one yard to yard so that I could just
go do what I do right you know I'm
saying so like those things where you
can make those easy plays to get guys
going right and then those other ones
deeper didn't we go down there I think
we're Erin I've never seen anyone it's
almost playing for like the Spurs and
then playing for the Golden State
Warriors yeah so like the way Aaron is
Aaron really just does his thing it just
makes it happen I've never seen anyone
could do what he does right right it's
like it's like watching John Wall or
somebody you don't care about this is
the greatest quarterback we've ever seen
yeah well I'm unbelievable the things
that he could do with a football right
oh you know different army yeah like
when the first day you threw the ball to
you were you like holy [ __ ] this thing
is unreal well one day I run a flat
round he threw me a no-look pass and it
hit me in a chest because he was looking
this way and he threw the ball I think
as a tight end
the Patriots office is more tight and
friendly right right so yeah the way
they move you around the routes and the
schemes and throwing in the middle of
the field
right I'm loves it throw in the middle
of the floor play action right you know
you like that you get the running game
going so you get the play and then right
at the top it's easier football because
we get so frustrated with Rodgers
because we look and we're like wow they
play like 11 personnel like 91 percent
of the time and we're just we just don't
see any creativity we don't see any ways
of getting you guys open it's more of
like Aaron nothing worked for the first
five create some [ __ ] and make it happen
yeah I don't learn how to scramble like
I never had to learn how to scramble
with the way - Aaron does like you know
saying I'll be in the middle of the
field I'll stop because everybody else
is going deep and he's like don't stop
just turn and run you know cuz he's
looking on the outside right edges so a
lot of the big plays happen when Aaron's
making them happy right happen and but
as a tight end you want to be in the
Patriots often of course right it's just
like if you there's a couple offices you
want to be in as a tight end
you won't be in a North Turner offense
yeah you know which is better do gates
what he did in San Diego although Jason
Witten is doing exactly bears defenses
offenses right just like it off North
Turner right you want to be in a
Patriots offense yeah and you want to be
in Andy Reid offense yeah you're right
because he's at LJ Smith Chad Lewis
Travis Kelce you're right it's all
that's one of the main options of us
Brent Celek
all right yeah four years so you want to
be in one of those offenses and there's
what it means like the way football is
that people who really know is notice is
that there's trees mmm so like all these
coaches are just branches of these other
coaches and they still do the same
things but they just put their little
tweaks on it Andy Reid's coaching tree
right now is one quarter of the NFL he's
crazy him and seven other coaches
there's eight guys underneath them yeah
it's nothing I just feel like I keep
asking sim specials all day no
unfortunately man one of them was tale
of two offenses it was pick another one
Martellus PR over this one has my name
on it yes it is Martellus P ah what's up
with your brow he's doing good he's an
Eagle fan over there whatever you want
on this [ __ ] podcast [ __ ] this yeah
that sounded crazy um I don't know what
happened there yet alright so that's me
I'm left go oh I've become the PR
manager of O'Dell three weeks ago I said
this is what Odell needs to do
everyone's talking about him not Karen
once a week put a video of him working
out and because the way social media
works people be like man he's grinding
for the last two weeks he's put one out
each Wednesday so I am now his PR
manager the bill is in the mail I am
wondering that an NFL player needs your
assistance since you understand the
media - what should levian do say to win
over the public while having this
contract dispute with the Steelers what
would your advice to be to a star as
they need to keep up that public they
want them on their side
I don't know why you want the public on
your side there really I think as a
player to understand that the fans are
for the team always so your job is to
come in as an entrepreneur to get the
best deal you could possibly get don't
worry about the fans worry about the
deal because that's what you're really
worried about
they got her you go out there and
perform on Sunday they gonna love you if
you let me on bail you have to worry
about anything because on Sunday you
catching the ball ten times and you run
it for 120 gotcha
you don't sound so like your performance
is what they should care about the most
now when it comes to business most of
the fans don't really understand the
business thing it's like oh you should
just take this or just be happy we've
signed you up for this and you signed it
this is what you deserve to get but
every single year teams cut players why
the deals are still on the table horse
but they never stick new players we got
four-year deal is really a visit once
the two years the guaranteed is gone oh
yeah we only talk about guaranteed money
because all that other stuff is nonsense
no one there's nothing all the back
loaded deals that look are pretty
propaganda yeah so just they just put
those numbers out there and and they're
cutting guys every year but as a running
back yo you have to you have to cash in
half to break so like you he put in the
work he deserves to get paid yes he
dessert like you wearing him out every
single year and taking another year off
his of his career right where he could
be cashing in so like now he has to come
out there take all the risk all of it
all of the risk for the care of your
team on his back and he's not like one
of those running backs who just pounds
the ball he really it's like him and
Tonio brown really do do their thing
book everything but him more so than
Antonio thank you I said this last week
Le'Veon is more valuable to the team
than Antonio because it'll still catch
you 80 balls
yeah and run it for a 1500 you and you
have to the past game does not work well
out the running game no right so when
you just talk about that with the
Patriots so when you got a really good
running game like you have a really good
running game they bring it an extra guy
down in the box you know that God comes
down now the faction is working and the
play-action is a beautiful thing if you
could run if you get your team to run a
play action or right because you power
on the power that's what we used to do
in New England we just beat Wow then we
were the same play play action off of it
there's a 40 yard game but most teams
aren't patient enough to keep running in
now they get three yards
four yards right you know understand
that a yard is a good place yeah the
attempt itself was a good play just a
running attempt to keep the defense
honest to go should I have to worry
about that yes
watch Alice pond it's behind me [ __ ] I'm
screwed you won't do another sim special
and nothing is better than running past
the line back and I said oh it's like a
quarterback when I used to hear the
tackle yell oh [ __ ]
that's nice [ __ ] I'm about to get hit
alright [ __ ] watch out watch out Chris
but I think there's a player like I
think your job is to perform right you
know I was the focus on being better and
performance sure so old Dale performs
yes right like none other
so he's putting up numbers the guy wants
to win like I think a lot of times like
if I think that race comes to playing it
- it - for sure it does we talked about
this no I'm just saying so like as a as
a young black male playing a game he's
hot-headed right right exactly
like I saw that's long ago like there's
no difference between what Odell does
and what Tom does yeah I guess about
when Antonio Brown knocked the the
Gatorade cooler he throws the Gatorade
core does Facebook live but yeah it's
like it's okay writing but Odell gets
he'll do a different standard but keep
going with a or Dez Bryant right yes Dez
Bryant wants to win yes guys so a lot of
times people like oh he's a hothead
so people build these stigmas around his
guy like I couldn't I remember going on
team and tio was on a team I heard all
this stuff about tio
he was the best teammate I had probably
one of the best teammates I had my
entire career Wow I've never met a
better guy like to play with who could
pull you to the side hey man
I should like tio how you cut like that
and he play one thing you need about
football is that don't try to cut like
another man there's things you could
take from the games but your feet are
different from his feet so we got what
works for you right and my whole career
Blake yeah that made someone sent you a
rookie commander Blake don't you ever
cut like a mud another man
take it you say was tea or juice take it
no there was a couple things though so
robo robo told me one time Romo told me
one time he said cuz when you don't play
a lot when you get in the game yeah like
I struggled in my early in my career
because I try to do too much right the
ball will be coming I'm like alright
he's right here I'm gonna turn this way
I won't break this tackle I'm gonna
break 150 yards and you drop the ball
drop it right right happened to me a lot
because I only get one pass in the game
and I felt like I had to make something
special yes I'm terrific happy right so
Romo used to tell me used to be like be
urgent but don't rush like some Jon
Gruden [ __ ] right there be quick but
don't rush or sometimes day yeah you're
5 I find myself you learn that one huh
you're 5 6 I might be urgent but don't
rush listen Gavin Escobar it's like he
wants you to get off the line of
scrimmage and have some urgency to it
but he doesn't want you to cut your
route short and see you supposed to go
10 yards out and go seven yards out yes
you're rushing yeah you rushed the play
in his timing and the mechanics of the
play but then I learned with Tom right
Tom will be like so I'll be running
browses like there's a feel for the game
right you know like our I stumbled off
the line I need to run they said the
timing is still the same right right
right
so like I've got like with Jay what I
learned it with Eli early in my career
cuz there was somewhere else like we're
under the basic route right and yar
didn't cut edit no tap with - were you
running that you settle down in the hole
what a sambac are used to try wide it
out so it takes you longer to get in
there right right and then you getting
closer to the defender anyway so we said
what Eli told me he's like just knife in
between them and just sit down with him
the mic was and I'm gonna hit you right
there right so I wouldn't run the whole
basic I'll just run to the Stein replace
them all mas just replace the mic back
right right in like so we learned like
we say when we were on top of - you know
like you got some routes where you could
sit down well I didn't really like Gill
Breyers offense yeah it was just too
much [ __ ] going on right you're gonna
read the coverages and everything
changed according to what the coverage
was right it's not that it was just like
its cover four and you can outrun a
safety go deep but if it's not you can't
outrun I run the basic so it's like you
making that decision on a fly and that's
all
I felt like that's why a lot through a
lot of interceptions right because he
may be thinking you may feel like you
could run past him but he may not feel
like you can do so and cover for
thangkas you could see the quarterback
because they flat footed it just backing
right right right they could break on
the ball while you doing you think
that's why Victor Cruz have a lot of
home runs got stutter and go and they'd
fall for that [ __ ] yes
whoever's Brady like what would you say
you're gonna go on and bro yeah so like
so when I'm with Tom I'm like Tom
sometimes I feel like if because the way
I read in rouse is almost like
basketball like once I got him I got him
I want to bring the ball back to him and
Tom was like if you feel like you should
break out I'm ready for you so it's like
that sometimes we'll go it's suppose to
be like a 10 yard rout at 7 I have to
cuz the linebacker you know if you get
him right here you got your elbow right
in this like riding massage you can push
off right there right two more steps and
he's behind you think he might undercut
you I need a brick right now because I
can't like there's only so many racking
I can maximize my distance away from him
right now let me cut yes and then he
would do it and he did you hit you
because he'd get in that shotgun and he
doesn't take a drop so he just gets the
ball and he's ready to go he could fill
your body right so the worst thing he
said if you go and break break right you
know don't be an in-between Oh
stuttering right so he could see you
give the lien and he knew tom is still
surviving because he's not hold on yeah
he wants to get it out if you open he
wants to get out let you do your thing
like a lot of quarterbacks like they hit
that deep Bob with a perfect throw yeah
he's like I'm gonna let you do your
thing like boom oh good a great great
job running with the ball yeah
alright we got two more here table
Turner and over/under week until I could
talk to in LA I know I'm going to see
LeBron be playing in the city yeah
you're not guard I didn't know all right
table Turner
okay Martellus is allowed to axioms and
left go any question he wants and they
have to answer we have to answer you can
ask any problem for me I'm an honest guy
no this guy ever here you got a watch
ever he will be us your pants off are
you married no not okay I'm married and
you can still ask me whatever you want
I'm just asking that I'm just wondering
he's straight
questions all right I got you you got
kids
yeah you could say I got - I got 11 year
old and a 7 year old what's your top
three animated films Oh Despicable Me is
number one okay for sure
Despicable Me is one The Incredibles are
you excited about the new one I am huh
yes I am very much excited you know the
credible of course there's nothing like
another great white superhero I probably
go the Shrek number three
Shrek is I have to push Shrek our Ice
Age it's one of those - I'm gonna go
with Shrek just because you're my Shrek
all the time though but because Mike my
friends in college used to make fun of
me because I'd like stay home and not on
a Friday night and I'd smoke weed and
watch Shrek instead of like one two go
out that's what the best thing about
retirement now reckon some other don't
ask me another
are you entender no that was a former
life about a year and that's like dog
years in today's times that's like four
years plus Sims doesn't matter and he
vouches for her which is rare yeah she's
cool she's cool people seriously yes
enum her full name is e nemesis
I'm not gonna give you like Madison then
I'd be like waking up with like a curse
on me
what's that okay so for you what's the
perfect date oh oh gosh I'm gonna say
the same thing that you said the best
thing about retirement is if I could
convince that to be a date I'm doing
that what the retirement okay so what's
the person what's a good night with her
like okay so say like
you want to do something a little
romantic alright I believe every day's
rough I tell my wife she's I mean I'm
lucky to have her but you're lucky to
have me to say you guys are the same
thing
Sims believes one side here so lucky for
you to be your daughter's father my
daughter's looking for me to be I said
my kids last night it's like you think
there's any other dads running around
playing ball tag in the house last night
and go I win my daughter sometimes she
could cry it up like look let's get this
right right now you could cry but the
world doesn't care
daddy cares I think you're yeah we're in
the same school reckoning but right now
yeah he does not care does not care so
you need to go figure out what you need
to do is stop yourself I'm crying and
then come holla at your daddy dude I
heard you talking on Simmons podcast and
I was like this is the tight end version
of Simms Simms does not believe he never
has to do anything for Valentine's Day
because he's been a Valentine all year
long but Valentine's Day is just a
ridiculous commercial I agree right
that's both a couple holidays that
shouldn't happen Valentine's Day okay
st. Patrick's Day oh yeah
Columbus Day yeah that's found it first
he ended up in a Bahamas by mistake yeah
raped everybody there took all they go
like re they have no more valuable
treasures here let's go find little
stumble upon something else came here
and did the same thing and he got a
holiday for discovery something that
already existed that's like me saying oh
I discovered your neighborhood I passed
it that's mine no [ __ ] I've been there
where thing is like man you guys are so
great to us I love all you Indian people
you guys are great so let's celebrate
together you guys have your traditions
with dance given I want to give thanks
to you guys it's cold winter is coming
so how about you I go to our boat we
have blankets for all of you and I
knowing they're all of them had smallpox
is that how it eventually write down I
always assumed it was like muskets or
something like things I don't know about
that part of the story I haven't heard
that part challenge Frank on that one I
got a heard that over-under was the last
one on
to ask you these and then I want to talk
about because we're gonna do some more
stuff with you later
but I definitely talked about the book
and the app and all that because yeah
we're making moves yeah we could talk
about me making moves my percentage of
NFL players truly speak their mind over
under five percent under five percent
men most of the guys would be lying to
ya to try to impress the fans on their
side and most of people that you see on
TV is not who they really are a lot of
these guys you think of great people
they're terrible people yeah and the
people that you think are terrible
people are great did like you saying
with Terrell Owens they're just great
people so it's it's it's yes he's left
Qo'noS he's no I've told them enough
stories yeah and some of the squeakiest
clean NFL guys all mister franchise guy
they're the slimy as dudes in the whole
league yeah they are they're terrible
yeah all right over/under what
percentage of the NFL smokes weed over
under 70% over over I made it a little
high yeah I think I would do 80% 80%
yeah so it's actually more shocking when
you meet someone the team that doesn't I
think is I mean there's miracle medical
marijuana yes so it's like there's times
that a year where your body just hurts
so bad that you don't want it to be
popping pills all the time Institute but
especially with all the stories now yeah
ruins your liver like there's a lot of
these anti-inflammatories that you take
for so long that like it starts to eat
at your liver kidneys and things like
that
and the human may that God may we yeah
well yeah exactly right I mean it's not
I think I think it's crazy that some
guys still have to do drug deals across
the world and then in California could
just go to you could go to in-n-out and
do walk right I know I know like one
state it's like you might go to jail for
doing this the other one that's like hey
go have fun but 80% I mean I think
that's he's right with 80% now not such
a long nine eighty nine percent I would
I would say this though not all these
guys are like it's smoke every night of
the week yeah you got offensive lineman
who's like he might only smoke on a
Friday night or once a month whatever
it's not like Gaza when people think
about people smoking weed smoke weed all
day they don't think of the couch
commercial with a woman like melted into
the couch that's how people visualize I
hate that commercial because they do
that with marijuana but then they show
people drinking alcohol and beer having
a great time yes they got the coolest
commercial where the guy's just driving
on the train through I smile and ice
cubes they're even worse for you well
that's doubt I mean the five doubles
things I've ever done in my life were
under the influence of alcohol period
not even close I mean the five dumbest
things I did in my life when I was in
was in Denver and I was talking to one
of police officers and I was just like
hey how much crime do you guys have
because of me it's like we never had to
really pull over anybody
the statistics are there's there's no
evidence of it to this point so seamless
delivered to my house I don't have to
leave anywhere all right last one
we're going down wormholes here how many
starting quarterbacks are better than
Colin Kaepernick over/under 15 starting
quarterback starting quarterbacks how
many in the league are better than
Kaepernick more or less than 15 here's
the team I mean I don't really know
there's the an estate of the
quarterbacks off top I mean in the NFL
there's really maybe eight benign elite
quarterback yes I would say it's in
there I know I'm listen it'sit's tough I
said during the systole I would have put
him I had him a little higher than that
I just said to be like if we were just
gonna be like okay this is the worst he
could possibly be right I think we put
him in like 25 that's the worst the
worst a certain just like they're
similar they all have strengths they all
have weaknesses so I mean he he's won
games right I mean your brother was
chasing around the field everywhere and
some of those chandi got you got to play
no doubt and even as last year coming
back after injury he wasn't even as bad
as people may know he was not I need you
to go back there they did the all or
nothing that year was I think was with
the Rams and Kaepernick was one of the
last games and he came back by himself
and had two touchdown drives to upset
the Rams in that game and I'm sitting
there I'm watching this guy running away
from people to go people say he can't
play and I just don't think people watch
and this
Dory's taking on so much now that they
don't even care anymore right well I
mean you have the owner of the the
Texans that go that one of Bob McNair so
he says I shouldn't apologize that's the
worst thing I did about the whole
situation not calling them inmates
running the asylum or so you see like a
lot of the stuff they say as ownership
is not really true they just trying to
say face as well you're right he did
just admit that he openly lied right he
didn't want to say sorry he didn't want
to say sorry but then he you know then
also though like people like oh and
daniels who played tight end for him
they they they second Dwayne Browns
account of him saying this so Obama yes
so so he's try to discredit you yes
right they try to discredit you tried to
discredit do the Wayne because the Wayne
doesn't play there so another player on
the team may not say anything right
right you know right and there's not a
lot of outspoken guys there's a lot of
guys who are in a closet man we should
do this we should do that right and then
when a team meeting come you stand up
and say something you'd be looking
around the crazy guy then afterwards
like yo man you really kicked ass doing
that man like bro you spoke for us
everything you said I felt in my heart
bro like I'm so glad that you said it
and we needed you to say that but
there's some things about change around
here boy man y'all trippin man so you
right now is an imagination agency yeah
Martellus Bennett imagination agents man
so you have an app you have a book what
do you want to talk about the most right
now I mean I just was exciting you me
everything I'm just excited about life
I'm super excited like I've always
wanted to make things and anyone any one
of my teammates that knows me know in a
sauna in a hot tub anytime I'm a bit
special teens periods I'm almost
thinking of things to make like I just
like to tell stories and as well that's
all that's just who I am
like I was never a athlete right I
learned to play sports I've always been
a creative I didn't learn to create how
did you do it right so I started my
company in imagination agency you know I
started in 2014 though when I was
playing with the bear so I released my
first book and I did my first app and
now I just released my second app in my
second book and this interactive
children's book
it'd mean actually what I did was I put
a party in your phone for your kids and
now they could party with the app that
made it sad book is narrated by me right
it's narrated by the girl that does the
AJ voice and then I must to start adding
guest voices really that's clear like
I'm gonna try to get Gronk the door
reading I know that's I wonder they want
to ask you about Gronk stuff too but I
love Gronk I know you do rock is way
smarter than y'all think I've said that
before he says he's like a savant like
he just picks up things immediately
beatings he was amazing because I worked
in New England before you were there oh
yeah cuz gark is pretty smart Gronk was
impressed with me - he's like no one's
ever learned to office as fast as you I
said I've been in like ten offices
there's only so much to crack so if they
want to see your app go to imagination
agency yeah you can just search hey J in
the App Store okay you could search
Martellus Bennett in an app store I work
sure I put that as one of the keywords
yeah I'm gonna check it out man my kids
my newest book is called hey Jase
bedtime my first book was called her age
a satyr it's a part of series and I got
a new I got a new animated film I'm
finishing up right now that I'm about to
score child Williams
now I'm gonna score myself really yeah
so um so mothers start scoring that and
we just finish up the animation for the
last episodes on that and I just
released another album I released the
album in February and another song I'm
releasing two more albums this year yeah
yes I'm solicited here and there are
makers and there are managers in this
life you're a maker your company is
gonna get big to where it's gonna need
you to manage don't stop making oh no
I've never stopped I know you won't I
couldn't like I've just seen it too many
times I never could stop making right so
that's like my biggest thing like my
entire career even when I was playing at
a high level of things I was always
making stuff like if I wasn't playing
like when I played for the Cowboys
actually was in an alternative hip-hop
group they used to tour no you know
called a moonshine kids we used to go
perform at all different types of places
so I used to there's times where like I
was telling somebody like one night I
ended up performing it was like Slim
Thug and um powwow but none of them
really knew me because I was just like a
just some big black guy that's saying
so I'm performing them like all kinds of
cool cool places and stuff like that and
so I used to perform a lot more and then
I started doing more art and I just
skateboard and wrote rollerblade and
stuff so I started doing more art and I
used to host art shows all the time I
just now started back painting so I'm
gonna start I think I might do a art
show this year probably closer to the
ESPYs awesome and and I always want to
make more me like I have like 10 musical
album projects that's out dude I could
tell your brain it's not the same as my
brain ok yeah so like I was so like
right now I'm super excited just about
life to be able to wake up and create
every single day because that's all I
want that's like my driving purpose in
life is just to make things I always
knew that I'm a storyteller I always
wanted to tell stories and in which form
of medium is should I story be told in
is it an app is a novel is a book I'm
actually writing my first adult book oh
right now and always sounds sounds so
dirty when I say that I was expecting
for a change of something 50 says 50
shades of football come on on to my new
book it's called forth in long three
points I would like to say this on both
of our yeah we are huge fans of you and
your brother really happen I mean we've
been here those phil simms
yeah exactly he's all right now but yes
we just would like to say we always have
appreciated your you and your brothers
honesty you're thinking outside the box
you're challenging the norms all of that
and I mean you were awesome thank you
people don't realize how good you were
I mean you you're a phenomenal fobel by
and your brother I'm not trying to be a
jerk here like your brother is one of
the best defensive players in the last
15 years in the league like he's that
phenomenal to me never got the credit he
deserves but we enjoyed watching both of
you play I'm not that good may not the
continue this thing going yeah pretty
sure people doesn't tire of me talking
right now like I never shuts up actually
I don't do that many interview you're
doing good your other than you're
sweating I mean I know I make people
nervous but it's okay now always I sweat
just because the next
we're back with a podcast show relax I
like the quarterback's I always sit
right behind a quarterback in meetings
yeah well you're smart yes oh
Martellus is so into this Mike Pope Mike
Pope
so Mike Pope told me like the greatest
tight end coach is every coach my dad's
giant C yes right yeah one of the
greatest coaches ever right and we'll go
down in history for as one of the
greatest Titan cultures ever and you
know he had a couple of health problems
this last couple years but planning for
him changed my my trajectory as a player
I was when I first got the New York like
this is why I always say like in Texas
you could be a horse but in New York you
could be a unicorn and and when I got to
New York he was my tight end coach my
first years have started because I saw I
was kind of nervous like I always knew I
could play right but I just I never had
a got the chance because I was behind
Jason Witten you never he tore his
spleen came out his back one game and
they taped it back up and he came back
and played right you know like so it's
just like I mean one day warming up for
a game he was supposed to be out his
ankles like the size of this microphone
or something like that and I'm warming
up in the starters and he was just
struggling all week to practice I'm like
I'm at the start is my chance and here
he comes jogging out the tunnel but he's
one of the greatest foot tight ends I
ever seen play - yeah a lot of people
think I hate Witten but I respect his
respect his game so much because he just
the way he ray aroused the technique
that he always used the way he played
the game yeah all around I always
respect to his game yeah but like Mike
Pope told me like I was playing with Eli
and Eli through me so everything every
time I kind of passed I was just super
excited because I get to catch that mini
you know sentence like when we first get
on Instagram you get a like you always
happy about it it means Russia gram [ __ ]
so go ahead so Mike comes back to me I
run back I score a touchdown like I'm
high five and a key Knicks and
everything and I run right back to the
sideline to Mike and he's like what
you're doing like I just came over he
told me he's like go get the quarterback
some sugar I was like
somebody's like like the horses when the
horses do something good give those
sugar just to make sure that you know so
like after that every time I got the
ball from Eli Blake sugar yeah Eli's a
great guy too I know he is he's funny
yes he's funnier to pay yes producer
Josh has been my ear for a strapless
dress all right Josh thank you got your
[ __ ] Josh fried jump to the microphone
yeah sure anytime you want
imagination agency go download the app
right now Sims break it down the college
linebackers all right we have been
talking about it for a long time we're
finally gonna do Sims as linebacker
break down we're gonna focus on the four
linebackers that are either getting a
lot of attention or in sims's mind
deserves a lot of attention do you want
to start off with ro Quan or Tremaine I
want to start off with Jermaine is he
your favorite linebacker miss Romania is
my favorite linebacker yes he is is the
physical freak he is he's one of my main
crushes of this draft for sure he's mine
I already picked him you already picked
him I he's my man crush okay fine you
can have him thank you first of I first
was amazed that his brother was the
safety on the team who's also very good
well we'll get two safeties at some
other point yes listen I'm just gonna
read I haven't read gone back and even
read these because it is like one of the
first positions I broke down right so
let's just make this plain and simple
this guy's one of the safest picks of
the draft he's one of the best players
in the draft he is definitely a top 15
pick it's just gonna depend where and
how the draft shakes out certain
positions whatever it may be
but he is a no-no can't miss no brainer
I mean who's your Pro powder comparison
Josh my pros and Anthony Bar
it was he's but he's better than Anthony
bars in middle he's reverse Anthony bar
if the bar member was at the edge where
we said oh we're gonna play some
linebacker for sure this kid is a middle
linebacker for real who can play defense
end
so he's like reverse Anthony no he's
better than Brian Urlacher houses size I
mean he's up to 53 it's unbelievable
okay so I'm just gonna read this
straight out I don't even know what I
wrote who cares okay
well I'm only a few plays in and Wow
hard for me to believe that there is any
linebacker in this draft that can be
this good okay so that's my first line
the size speed combo is special as it
gets for a middle linebacker kind of
gnat and he's a natural ball Hawking
middle linebacker like legit value as an
edge rusher if you want to move him
there he can play three four outside
linebacker without a doubt but I still
think he's best as a middle linebacker
he's like a reverse Anthony bar just a
better football player than Barr was in
college Wow Plus this kid is a natural
middle linebacker okay only weakness at
this point is teams take advantage of
his overall aggressiveness right cuz he
go that's college it's college and
sometimes there's a play-action he can't
wait to kill the running back and he
goes up there and they go there's
somebody behind it okay so yes it's not
perfect nobody is okay but they take
advantage of his overall aggressiveness
and his quickness to diagnose plays
which I thought was extremely impressive
I mean this is not just some meathead in
the middle just like oh there's a ball
I'm gonna go get it so why is he top 15
and not top 10 position yeah yeah I just
that was just being safe I think he is a
top 10 because that's my thing is what
if five quarterbacks go oh no I get it I
mean we have all these knocks from some
of the corners knocks on some of the
safeties and there's one offensive
lineman there's one defensive end right
but you know that if this guy is gonna
be the middle of your defense for ten
years it's like when CJ Mosely went like
15 of the Ravens and everyone's like
he's a lock I'll be a Pro Bowler his
whole career I'm sitting there going the
why not drafting him earlier yeah I get
that because of positional need I guess
so but this is on the the he's gonna be
the captain to your defense right well
also maybe positional need for your own
team right where they just go like we
don't need a linebacker here maybe they
need a linebacker and a tackle or a
guard and they're like gosh it's Nelson
or Jermaine well you know whatever I
don't know so that I'm just saying that
we believe that game-changing linebacker
game-changing that's yeah that's rare I
know that's why I mean I haven't seen
many mock drafts I mean I've seen like
the Raiders they're gonna take a
linebacker right a lot I'm seeing
Jermaine possibly going to the Raiders
to the Niner
right to the dolphins right mom Yeah
right there at 11:00 and then I also
think that I don't think the Colts but
you never know know maybe that high at
6:00 yeah but I mean probably not that
high at 6:00 but I mean end of the day I
just wrote hey the ability to pursue
ball carriers is absolutely amazing he
plays faster than his four or five for
speed at the combine which is sets the
edge gets off box even when he's in a
disadvantage in blocks he still gets off
and he's a phenomenal what I call a
green dog Blitzer which is like
basically he's covering the running back
man-to-man and then he flies in because
he's so explosive quarterbacks go oh
he's not coming and then the next thing
they look back in they're like oh [ __ ]
he's in my face yes he's here but bit
for a tall middle linebacker I wrote
he's very good at taking on cup box
coverage is off the charts
so his open field tackling good
discipline understands his assignments
really really impressed with this kid
for a tall guy he can really fight
through trash yeah bottom line kid is no
brainer definitely one of the best best
I have watched special top-15 mate maybe
top 10 4 3 3 4 probably best in 3 4 I
wrote best in 3 yeah I love them yeah I
I saw about the combine I was like who
is this cyborg that is running right he
I mean he is he's phenomenal so ro Quan
is more traditional yeah Kwan's the one
that won all the awards he won like the
defensive awards right that he was
amazing at Georgia yes I think this guy
is special too I agree I met him in
person right really nice guy you know
he's got the great smile he looked like
he was running for governor of Georgia
right the nice pressed khakis right you
could tell he's like very focused but
every time I watched him he had that
sideline to sideline gear that when it
went on the running back almost got
scared like running back chopped his
feet a little bit right
what did you say yeah I mean I think
you're spot-on with some of your
assessment for sure I mean Edmunds is a
freak of nature right so that's why I
put him one so rare you see a guy like
this this guy is awesome I mean he's
awesome he's he's your you know Ruben
Foster
he's your Bobby Wagner type they were
comparing a lot to Dion Jones yeah sure
I could see that too
yes I could I think you I think
actually might be a better overall
player than Dion was coming out dia was
just pure athleticism yes I feel like
this kid has a better a little bit
better feel for the game overall but I
just I wrote this I wrote firstly six
one he's 236 I saw him in person he's
impressive looking he is and I wrote
this I would he wouldn't stop talking
about his trap all his makeup artist she
kissed kept going she goes what is this
how do they get that high I mean he's
he's made of steel just another guy and
his in his legs and a sore top touch I
mean there are tens out of tens Wow it
was it was it looked good okay I will
say this to start I didn't mean it to
come out good I will say this to start
he is more explosive than film than on
TV has great compact build and a great
pair of legs he's a lot like Ruben
Foster's film from last year except this
kid has a better build and natural
thickness I think his acceleration is
better than Foster hips not as good as
in coverage he definitely has a more
explosive he's definitely a hair more
explosive than Foster or even Edwards
from Virginia Tech not yeah Edmund sorry
not as good getting off blocks or
blitzing reading read and react as
Edmunds but still both very good let's
see other than taking on blockers and
shielding them I should say this it's
being picky I mean the kid is awesome so
I guess I was trying to say there I'm
reading too fast but there are times
when he can get stuck on blockers right
gotcha smaller right he can't get off it
sometimes there was a few times they
play a three-four defense where the
guard would get on him and he just
couldn't get off I mean uh it wasn't
like I was like oh we're knocking him
out of the first round
waiting Nelson was talking about face
him he's like he's just all over these
all over the place he really is so is he
a 4:3
he is a 4:3 true middle linebacker
Friday yes he is he is I mean or it
could be like a will linebacker which
sometimes it's the more athletic guy if
you're the Raiders yeah and you need a
middle linebacker
I need a defensive lineman yeah and Vito
Vega sitting there and rook Juan Smith
sitting there yeah I got a I haven't
watched all Evita veía yet so that's
like one of my next positions is D
tackles but I would probably go with RO
Quan Wow
you like him a lot yeah it's just it's
such a valuable position this day and
age in the NFL that's what I'm saying
with the running backs and having a
cover all that stuff yep offenses all
that stuff yeah I mean I just wrote like
Edmonds he's a tremendous open field
tackle er he could play for three or
three four but I thought I said in the
NFL I think he's best suited for the 4-3
he's a Bobby Wagner Rueben foster type
hmm let's see oh oh oh I wrote this
Oklahoma game is different for Smith
more speed passing misdirection type of
game not what he's used to in the SEC
and he struggled a little bit in that
game just because it was different from
what he had been used to yes you know
that big 12 he had I'm playing here to
get used to playing flag football for
the first time all year but let's see I
wrote Edmonds I compared them a lot to
each other so I'd refer admins more
impressive in this type of game verse
Clemson the misdirection got got off
guards and tackles a little bit better
there than Raekwon Smith did but at the
end of the day him and Edmonds both
awesome
I give edge to Edmonds because of the
size and the ability to get off blocks
but this kid is also a top 5 or I mean
top 10 or top 15 pick awesome yeah
number 3 in terms of line back yes a lot
of people yeah have latent vander ash as
the guy right the Boise State linebacker
he'll be the first man ever invited to
the draft who played eight-man football
in high school from Salman Salmon River
High School in Riggins Idaho right I
asked you a few weeks ago yeah what do
you think about this Layton Vander Esch
I mean Scouts love this kid what do you
think about I don't love him I will say
that right off the bat in fact I didn't
even think about this until you just
started bringing up who was the kid that
got drafted at a Boise that went to
Chicago in the first round in the middle
linebacker Shane McCloud Shane McCloud
this is what would scare me it's the
same type of guy really I think at the
end of the day so being biased because
they both want the Boise no I don't
think I am I think it's gonna be the
player you'll see what I say here I
really don't like he's six for each two
but I do think he's one of the more
overrated guys in the draft not saying
he's he's NFL caliber linebacker we know
that he's not like in the 15 or 20 is
the first round I would have a hard time
taking him in the first round I'm just
gonna throw that out there right now
I would hi everybody this is so this is
the one thing I hear okay right away
when I taught when I watch or hear
anybody on TV watch the organ game okay
well I watch the organ game okay I mean
I could have made most of those tackles
I mean he [ __ ] stood there and there
was a big hole and then running back ran
right into him oh my gosh I mean so is
their athleticism they're certainly but
that would be a game where I'd go like
you're just cherry picking a game and
going oh you look at all these tackles
and you're not really evaluating the
quality of the tackle or what are you to
do to make them right talk about this
with Chris Borland all the text it's
like 18 tackles and 19 and 16 of them
were like centers right and sometimes
the game just blaze it up on a silver
platter for you coach call the Blitz
through this gap and they ran the ball
right there I'm amazing look how awesome
I did but okay tall and long with a body
that looks like it will continue to fill
out high cut waist long legs long arms
looks like a Keith Bullock Brian
Urlacher type of linebacker I would say
no way he was 256 pounds during the
season
looks like 242 to 245 to me and I'm an
expert at looking at naked men and I'm
probably right okay
impressed with his side to side
movements good quicks good ability in
and out of transition straight speed not
all that impressive build up speed not a
lot of explosion or acceleration and out
of all the linebackers I had watched at
this point he's the least physical
Lineback least physical linebacker I've
watched it's a little concerning not
real physical taking on blockers doesn't
square people up edges them with his
shoulders haven't seen him really laid
the wood on anybody yet I wrote alright
so then I wrote but and I I don't I
don't think this kid can play a middle
linebacker in the NFL he's not a
physical enough not willing enough to
throw his body around he's on the ground
too much he leans and loses balance when
tackling or taking on box not not a not
so sure this kid is not a better fit for
a three-four outside linebacker that's
what I broke that's where I think he
should be like a TJ wah exactly right
and he's not as strong or as powerful as
TJ is right so where's the positive in
here so the positive is he's tall he's
big he is athletic right but I just
don't love the football aspect of it
he's got something to prove to me
therefore and that to me just I can't
take
in the first round about that that's too
that's too questionable for me so let me
see where IRA yeah IRA here we go organ
game lots of tackles I wrote silver
platter though Oregon style fits him
speed space game he got to make tackles
didn't have to square anybody up and lay
the wood right it was perfect for him
and then I wrote I like this kids an
athlete he's very fluid good side to
side moving but not twitchy explosive
enough for middle linebacker wouldn't be
a metal linebacker on my team has value
as a coverage linebacker and on past
situations but traditional my
traditional middle linebacker stop very
average hmm yeah so what round do you
think he is well I'd for me he'd be a
second-round type of guy like I would
say somewhere between 35 and 50 mmm
but I bet I don't think people are
falling for it I think they just fall
for the size and measurables I really do
I think that's really what it comes down
to a lot of times when you want a lot of
awards and he put up a lot of big
numbers I mean I mean he looks apart all
that I get that and maybe they think
there's potential there
yeah but I'm always wary of anybody with
potential at that position who doesn't
want to just throw their body around you
need to see a little reckless and I have
to yeah reckless and I mean yeah wait
till you see Zack Martin on your ass and
then you're gonna go holy [ __ ] this
shit's reckless
so I'm swearing a lot today so you have
Evans as the third line bhagavan's
better than him alright so this is the
of this is the Alabama linebacker right
he's a first round linebacker to me this
guy is the first rail line back yeah
yeah this is the surprise first for a
linebacker that we talked about last
week right he is okay so six three two
thirty - right that's what Evans is let
me get up his profile just so I got it
here but 6-3 232 kid has a good look
he's like a he's like a longer version
of row Quan Smith or Foster from last
year and then I wrote actually he's just
CJ Moseley that's who he is
he's CJ Moseley except just maybe not
quite as explosive but very good in
coverage very fluid better hips than row
Kwan Smith in Georgia who runs really
well yeah his ability
kind of open up and things like that
where row quanta is like let me redirect
my body and then I'm gonna be a
heat-seeking missile straight away
this guy could turn his hips and turn
with tight ends running down the middle
just a little more fluid than a broken
we're talking about Rashad Rashad Evans
exactly right
runs really well has good acceleration
but he is not as explosive as an athlete
as Edmonds or Smith good wiggle really
is an act to go sidestep and and in
avoid blockers and make it tackle still
I thought that was actually really
impressive solid consistent tackler not
gonna try to knock people's heads off
like Smith from Georgia but does have
that type of explosion and legs on
contact does it have that explosion or
legs on contact excuse me let's see
discipline is what you expect from a
Bama linebacker not uh he's not quite
them the middle linebacker ball hawk
that Moseley or Foster were before him
still this kid has no weakness to his
game like the other two middle
linebackers just not quite as good like
Edmonds from Virginia Tech is very
skilled Blitzer who has value as an edge
rusher in certain situations which he
does I mean that's what Alabama does
it's like when I studied Donte Hightower
when I was working for the Patriots he
played middle linebacker but in certain
situations he played like defense end
and he would rush like he sounds like
Evans might be a good opportunity for
the Patriots at 21 or 30 oh you know
what you're exactly he's he is for sure
he'd be their type of guy if they need
those multiple guys know dat seven and
they've kind of lost a bunch of them I
hear you're exactly right and I didn't
really think about that but yes he could
be the type of guy they look for at 21
or 32 wherever he ends up Eagles have 32
okay I roll better and coverage and
Smith and better and trash than Smith
but not by enough where I'm gonna say he
is better all-around player than Smith
gotcha strength a point of attack bend
around the edge really impressive really
impressive at DN for a long frame but
what the hell did I write here strength
that point over there who cares let me
just go to the next one end of the day
kid is usually is really a good player
with no weakness in coverage or getting
off blocks but overall just as not as
gifted physically as Edmonds or
Smith I wrote 22:35 he has room to get
bigger and thicker as well so do you
like this linebacker crop that you've
seen I don't love it I gotta say like
out of the other guys that I've watched
whether that's like Malik Jackson of
Texas I mean solid but not special I'm
trying to think of some of the other
guys hold on I'm just gonna make sure I
pull them all up here just so I don't
mess this up the Dean those the teams
but overall no it's not a real image
remain a special role Quan is it sounds
like his beyond solid like he has doubt
he's like like little pieces of special
but he's a really good player yeah Evans
is like a little bit lower than that but
he's like super clean and knows it right
and then Layton sounds a little bit like
a project I mean yeah a project or
really more of a projection to me like I
mean you have to project that he's gonna
play a certain way that you didn't
really see on film in the NFL or you
have to go I think he's a three-four
outside linebacker type I mean we'll be
like such a good linebacker coach like
Mike Zimmer that you can get a guy like
Anthony bar and like you can just train
them because that's your expertise yes
certainly I mean listen there's a lot of
things to like but I just saw the film
with Leighton Van Dhiresh did not come
anywhere near his athletic testing right
gotcha
it just was not as Tremayne it matched
it was better remember I wrote he wrote
he actually plays faster than four or
five for M roll Quan yet not this
freakiest Jermaine but like roll Quan
and Jermaine Edmonds they can be
multiple all-pro type linebackers that's
what kind of skill they have where Evans
could be a Pro Bowler and if the year
goes right and maybe an all-pro at some
point but he's definitely a starting
linebacker for a long all I was gonna
say you should tell Kyle to make sure he
takes Edmonds there at nine but the true
thing is they won't have that pick cuz
they're gonna be sending it to the New
York Chinese guys thank you so much for
joining us as always we love you very
much
thank you so much for the iTunes reviews
we're closing in on nine hundred which
is pretty awesome cool and as well
thanks for checking us out on YouTube
and if you could go to the web ease and
vote for us we want to knock off Bill
Simmons as the top podcast and Simms
will do something insanely embarrassing
if we get the win for sim peace out
homies for Fender ik good evening in the
lef koe man says good night well
hollered you guys soon enjoy the rest
your day will be back with episode 161
later this week see ya